steals the runner at first phillies have
stolen efficiently as a team
[Music]
flags it down there's one and there's
two
wow the gold glover takes the short hop
and turns it into two
[Music]
line drive caught by alec ball no play
at first
after he jumped he came down with
holding his groin
yeah something's uh uncomfortable right
now
now watch him at the great play of
course 6'5 doesn't hurt but
see him right there he grabs it
he tweak something
takes that one upstairs and javi draws
the walk patrick wisdom will come up to
him
with the bases loaded the count no balls
and two strikes
and a breaking ball and a call strike
three
that was a pretty nasty curveball it may
have finished off the plate the home
plate umpire nick lentz
felt like it went across the plate
he tied him up a 94 mile an hour
fastball and matt moore
gets back-to-back strikeouts
to wrap up a bases loaded situation here
in the first
throws a lot of balls so you don't think
he has command but a lot of them are
intentional it's softly off the end of
the back corner takes it in throws to
first the good job by zach davies
pitches around jake digs in and matt
moore goes back to work
drives that one center field herrera
back and looking and it's gone
marissa will touch them all his fifth of
the year and he continues to do the
damage against the lefties one nothing
comes
next day yesterday in cincinnati picks
right up here this evening
oh baby you talk about
center square here's andrew knapp to
lead it off
that ball was launched to deep right
field and it is gone wow long gone for
andrew knapp his second home run of the
year and he's just tied it up at one
and all the coaches watches are
pinging right now because there's a
score update out in chicago babies try
to throw it look like a change up 77
miles an hour yep and look where it is
belt high out over the plate
that's crushed out towards right center
and that one will take a bounce and hit
off off the ivy bryant towards third
willy's gonna send him on his way to the
plate a rock at rbi double
javier baez gives the cubs the lead
to one
set down the last five in a row
gregorius
galt out to right field brian going back
and it is gone what a gap what a grab
dede gregorius smokes one into the
bleachers to tie this game up in two two
solo home runs tonight for the phillies
and for dede his sixth home run of the
year
off the hands ground ball to second
booted by segura they're going to come
home with it and that's bad base running
by horner a break for the phillies that
horner
is cut down going home
and the inning is over
e4
to allow contreras to reach 4-2 on the
put out
will go to the fifth
miller at first three and two two outs
payoff pitch
left field playable peterson
and he gets out of it
davies pumps his fist
bouncer over to third
bowl he's got it
and in time to get bios 5-3 on the put
out solid 1-2-3 inning for connor
brogdon
we played five we go to the sixth tied
up at two
so here we go three and two brothers
deals
oh my
[Applause]
a little bit low said nick lentz
go ahead run he just got run i think
ross is saying you let him talk you into
that
nine games of frustration built up
if joe's body language is so bad they're
dismissive
plus he's gonna keep making his point
and joe tries to
waltz him back to the dugout i mean it's
it's a borderline pitch it might have
been down a little bit
[Applause]
line drive to left field that's it for a
base hit going to the corner harper's
around second going to third base
peterson peels it off the wall harper's
heading home the throw to the plate will
not get there
it's an rbi double for mccutcheon his
second double of the night and the
phillies take the lead three to two
that one's hit out toward left that's it
for a base hit rounding third is
mccutcheon he'll score hoskins stops at
first rbi single phillies have built a
4-2 lead yeah that's the reese hoskins
we like staying in the middle of the
field
line drive caught by connor brogdon on
the mounds
easy connor wow
l-1
best athletes on the field timer pitcher
just remember that that one came back
pretty good
broken back ground ball segura to second
for one gregorius over to first in time
a four six three double play that's a
beauty
the base is loaded and two outs
phillies have used miller jankowski and
thereas off the bench
now over to third kicked off so guarded
to shallow left field one run is in here
comes hoskins he'll score and the
phillies add a couple more it's seven to
two here in the top of the eighth inning
that ball was hit hard but it is an
error charge to sogard phillies have
scored three in the inning and they lead
by five
oh duble out toward left center field it
is gone
it's a three-run home run for herrera
and the phillies have busted this ball
game wide open it is now a 10-2 game
here on the top of the eighth inning so
much for the cubs bullpen being one of
the best
in the national league not tonight
that's blasted right field forget it
is the other way
hobbies hit some rockets here tonight
yeah you know lost in the shuffle now
this lopsided game javi baez has been
very good here tonight
first time up good at bat second time
doubled into the gap in right center now
goes oppo for the long ball